trop c'est trop le message estclair
Daniel tarvellaa bonsoir vous êtes le
président dans les evelines de la
Fédération française du bâtiment Renault
Alcatel Virgin des entreprises qui
focalisent toutes les attentions on en
parlait d'abord d'ailleurs il il y a
quelques instants pardon sur ce plateau
mais le bâtiment aussi va très mal très
mal vous le dites avec ce mot d'ordre
trop c'est trop vous allez nous
expliquer dans un instant ce que
signifie ce mot d'ordre et cette
opération c'est un constat nationale
tout d'abord avec une baisse de
l'activité on va donner quelques
chiffres mais en ce qui concerne le
département des ivelines il y a une
véritable inquiétude aujourd'hui une
baisse de l'activité dans le bâtiment
mais bon il y a eu une baisse d'activité
au cours de l'année passée puisque
elle était de l'ordre de 1300 emplois
bon et puis vous avez vous on constate
que depuis quelques années il y a un
certain nombre de mesures qui sont
prises par des des gouvernement
successif qui toutes tendent à pénaliser
la l'activité de des entreprises du
bâtiment je citer pour mémoire
l'augmentation de la TVA bien sûr la
sortie du taux du taux de l'ancien du
taux à du prêt à taux zéro pardon
l'augmentation de la CSG l'augmentation
du délai de détention d'un bien qui a
été porté de 15 à 30 ans avant de
pouvoir être exonéré bon toutes choses
qui sont négatives et qui ont une
incidence et en ce qui concerne l'année
à venir c'est-à-dire 2013 notre
fédération
nationale considère que cela va donner
lieu à une baisse d'activité de l'ordre
de 3 et5i % ce qui entraînerait 40000000
emplois de moins sur la France entière
en ce qui concerne notre département je
pense que le taux risque d'être
légèrement supérieur peut-être 4 4 et
demi % ce qui entraînera une perte
d'emploi de 1300 à 1500 emplois de
nouveau est-ce que des entreprises ont
fermé et surtout est-ce que le solde est
négatif entre les créations
d'entreprises dans le bâtiment et les
disparitions alors je je peux pas
répondre exactement à la question ce que
je peux vous dire c'est qu'effectivement
déjà en cours d'année au cours des 6
derniers mois de l'année dernière on a
vu beaucoup d'entreprises qui ont fermé
volontairement ou par cessation
d'activité par dépôt de bilan
volontairement c'estàd qu'elles ont
anticiper éventuellement difficultés
àenir et fa absolumement c'est qu'elles
n'ont pas attendu d'avoir des
difficultés de déposer de bilan mais
simplement par découragement et parce
que il y a trop de trop de contraintes
et ce phénomène manifestement est en
train de s'accélérer en début d'année
aujourd'hui la réalité pour un chef
d'entreprise dans le bâtiment ce sont
des carnets de commande à un mois
environ c'est ça c'estàdire très peu de
visibil plus de la moitié de nos
adhérents ont effectivement un un carnet
de commande qui est un mois ou inférieur
à un mois quelquesunes ont deux ou 3
mois d'avance mais ce mais pas plus je
parle encore une fois pour nos
entreprises qui je le rappelle tout de
même sont des petites structures à 80 %
de moins de 10 effectivement assez peu
de de salariés vous l'avez compris hein
si vous nous suivez Le Bâ qui traverse
une véritable crise aussi bien au niveau
national que dans le département des
ivelines pourtant dans le département
des ivelines justement ça représente 7 à
9 % de l'activité économique c'est ce
que vous avancez 10 % 10 % de l'activité
économique du département effectivement
et vous n'avez pas le sentiment d'être
soutenu pour autant non par qu'on vous a
reçu sur ce plateau il il y a quelques
temps et vous nous disiez les politiques
nous écoutent pas en tout cas les
politiques de la nouvelle majorité les
socialistes les députés socialistes par
exemple ne vous ont pas écouté ne vous
ont pas reçu est-ce que les choses ont
évolué ces derniers mois heureusement
non puisque depuis la dernière fois
effectivement j'avais indiqué que
j'avais pu
rencontrer certains élus de de
l'opposition mais que en ce qui concerne
la majorité gouvernementale actuelle
malgré nos sollicitations et malgré
aussi les promesses qui nous ont été
faites nous n'avons toujours pas pu
rencontrer qui que ce soit alors afin de
structurer votre action vous avez lancé
au niveau national donc avec les
différents départements français
l'opération trop c'est trop l'objectif
vous l'avez compris c'est dénoncé ces
mesures que vous jugez donc néfastes
pour la construction avec les réalités
que vous nous avez énoncé au-delà de
tout ça le 31 janvier il y aura
concrètement une journée qui sera
organisée qui permettra de porter vos
revendications alors plus exactement
c'est l'opération trop c'est trop va
consister essentiellement à envoyer aux
élus aux décideurs de toute la France
entière et nous pour de notre
département des euh cartes euh disant
donc trop c'est trop où l'on voit les
entreprises qui jouent le jeu qui sont
surchargées de de de charg social c'est
le cas de le dire et qui ont beaucoup de
de contraintes qui n'existent pas pour
une certaine concurrence déloyal je veux
citer par là d'une part
l'auto-entrepreneur qui ne paye pas de
TVA qui n'a pas les mêmes charges et
puis aussi les entreprises étrangère
européennne qui dans le cadre de la
législation européenne peuvent se
permettre de venir nous concurrencer en
payant moins de charges que nous mais
les auto-entrepreneurs ça reste une
concurrence marginale malgré tout mais
ça reste pas une concurrence marginale
puisqueencore une fois dès lors que nous
avons nous beaucoup d'entreprises qui
ont un caractère artisanal ils sont
directement en concurrence avec avec les
entau-entrepreneurs j'en reviens à cette
journée du 31 janvier il est prévu
concrètement de présenter vos projets
alors alors à partir du 31 janvier donc
ces cartes vont être envoyées à tous les
élus pour notre part dans les ivelines
nous avons un petit peu anticipé le
mouvement puisque nous avons lancé
l'opération le 21 janvier qui était le
jour où nous avons procédé à la
cérémonie des vœux donc nous avons oui
et en revanche une manifestation va
avoir lieu à Paris au à la Maison de la
Chimie le 6 mars prochain pour appuyer
tout ça donc ce que nous demandons ce
que nous demandons bien sûr c'est d'être
soutenu et d'avoir en quelque sorte un
petit peu un plan de relance du bâtiment
avec quelques mesures phar nous
souhaiterions que la TVA par exemple
revienne à 5 % lorsqu'il s'agit de
construction sociale ou de travaux de
d'aménagement de d'économie qui vise
l'économie d'énergie nous souhaitons
également que le temps de détention d'un
bien avant exonération soit réduit même
si on ne le ramène pas à 15 ans qu'il
soit au moins ramené à à à 20 ans nous
souhaitons également que les gens qui
ont droit au prêt à taux zéro puissent
différer le remboursement des intérêts
durant la le temps d'amortissement du
capital et puis nous souhaitons
également que l'auto-entrepreneur soit
sorti du bâtiment vous avez le sentiment
qu'avec ces différentes mesures vous
pourriez obtenir des résultats tout de
suite parce qu'il y a aussi une certaine
morosité un climat ambiant assez
difficile he chacun chacun sait que le
bâtiment est un secteur où il y a un
temps de latence un temps de réponse qui
est relativement long mais ça pourrait
être un commencement ça pourrait être un
commencement avec ces différentes
propositions que vous avez évoqué malgré
tout comme on l'évoquait d'ailleurs tout
à l'heure avec les syndicats de la CGT
en parlant de de Renault on imagine mal
le gouvernement euh vous donner la carte
blanche et permettre la mise en place de
l'ensemble de ces mesures ben on peut
effectivement toujours espérerexte
économiqueile bien sûr mais je voudrais
tout de même rappeler si vous voulez
bien pour terminer d'une part que euh le
bâtiment le secteur du bâtiment lorsque
les gens ont de l'activité ils sont
créateurs d'emploi et d'emplois non
délocalisés hein puisque j'ai entendu
dans vos sujets précédents que la
délocalisation est un sujet épineux et
puis je voudrais aussi rappeler que le
secteur du bâtiment est encore l'un des
RAR secteur où ce qu' l'on a coutume
d'appeler l'ascenseur social est une
réalité dans la mesure où on peut
parfaitement imaginer de commencer comme
apprenti de devenir compagnon devenir
chef d'équipe chef de chantier ingénieur
et pourquoi pas chef d'entreprise
j'aimerais juste aussi qu'on fasse une
parenthèse avec ces difficultés dans le
secteur du bâtiment on imagine aussi que
l'apprentissage la formation est rendu
difficile les jeunes ont du mal à
trouver des des entreprises par les
temps qui court bien évidemment les
jeunes ont du mal à trouver des
entreprises cela étant nous continuons à
former des des des des apprentis et
Bonan Malan nous formons sensiblement
800 apprentis sur le département des
ivelines merci pour toutes ces
précisions Daniel Taravella et donc
cette mobilisation du bâtiment ce sera à
Paris vous nous l'avez dit le 31 janvier
pour poursuivre cette action avec pour
mot d'ordre trop c'est trop Merci à VOUS
Valérie oribo va me rejoindre pour la
chronique de l'environnement et ce soir
de précieux conseils notamment pour
limiter sa facture électrique juste le
temps de vous dire que la finale du
concours gastronomique créé en 194 87
par le cuisinier français Paul Bocuse
vient de débuter à Lyon c'était tout
juste aujourd'hui 56 sélection nationale
trois sélections continentales 24 chefs
du monde entier finalement réunis sur de
jours dont thbao rudgeri le chef de la
création salé chez le nautre vous le
voyez cette société est installée à
plaisir il se prépare depuis le mois de
septembre presque 24h sur 24 7 jours sur
7 12 pays ont déjà relevé le défi lors
de la compétition aujourd'hui mardi pour
les 12 autres dont la France dontb bgéie
ce sera demain mercredi il aura 5h35 et
pas une minute de plus pour faire la
différence sur ces différentes
réalisations et nous vous tiendrons bien
sûr informés de ces résultats et puis il
sera aussi sur notre plateau dès son
retour dans le département des Yvelines
je vous propose dès à présent de vous
rendre sur notre site Internet pour
regarder d'ailleurs le portrait que nous
lui avions consacré pour suivre un petit
peu sa préparation à plaisir et puis
sachez que le dernier bcus d'or français
c'était en 2007 avec Fabrice DVG on
espère que le prix reviendra en France
et pourquoi pas dans le département des
ivelines de l'ombre à la lumière d'un
salon de coiffure au plateau de
télévision c'est l'aventure menée par
Émilie Therre coiffeuse à Montini le
Bretonneux que vous allez rencontrer dès
à présent et vous avez peut-être déjà vu
son travail puisqu'elle officie
dorénavant sur les plateaux de la star
academie émilie est coiffeuse à Montini
de Bretonneux depuis plus de 10 ans cela
fait même plusieurs années qu'elle gère
son propre salon mais il y a quelques
mois émilie a découvert l'univers de la
télévision en travaillant sur l'émission
de la Star Académie pour changer du
quotidien de travailler en salon c'est
une expérience sympa que je pense
beaucoup de coiffeurs aimerait faire
pendant leur carrière c'est différent
parce que là on travaille quand même
beaucoup en équipe que en salon on est
individuellement sur notre client là bon
voilà on a les consignes on peut être à
deux sur une même
personne c'est sympa parce que on se dit
que notre coiffure va passer à la télé
donc on est assez fier de ça intervient
sur les primes du jeudi soir au sein
d'une équipe d'une dizaine de coiffeurs
coupe couleur brushing extension toutes
les techniques sont employé pour
respecter les instructions de la
production j'ai coiffé qui j'ai romain
j'ai eu Jimy en homme j'ai coiffé prof
aussi les deux femmes prof sans oublier
Vanina candidate venant de versaill
Émilie qui officie dans les coulisses de
la Star Academy n'a pas été recruté par
la production mais par par l'entreprise
générique basée dans les Yvelines
partenaire coiffeur sur l'émission de
télé réalité ils fournissent au
programme les produits capillaires et
les équipes de professionnels tout au
début il y avait 15 candidats donc
effectivement on était une dizaine ce
jeudi là il y avait combien de coiffeurs
alors là on était 7 SEP coiffeurs et et
on finit normalement à 34 sauf pour le
dernier prime où là tous les candidats
vont revenir donc là on va être à
nouveau je pense à peu près une dizaine
de
le budget investi par l'entreprise
générique pour cette publicité se
chiffre à plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'euros mais la retombée sur leur
clients professionnel et surtout
particulier est déjà très positive